-So "Wine Country."
I'm so excited.
I'm going to go to the premiere.
All you guys are in town
on Wednesday.
-Yes.
-These are --
These are
our dream team friends.
-Yes.
-It's you, Poehler, Dratch,
Maya Rudolph.
Tina's in the film.
-Emily Spivey and --
-Emily Spivey and Liz Cackowski
wrote it.
-And Paula Pell...
-And Paula Pell.
-...who's going to be, at 56,
the greatest discovery
ever to come to film.
-A comedy gold mine.
-It's a powerhouse. Yes.
-And this is actually --
this film is based
on an actual birthday weekend...
-Yes.
-...you guys all took
for Rachel Dratch.
-That's right.
We celebrate marquee
birthdays together.
-Yep.
-And we did go to Sonoma
to celebrate Dratch's birthday.
And a lot of the sort of
tentpoles of the movie
are based on real moments
that we spent for Dratch's --
and we also did it
for my birthday.
Two years ago,
we went to Palm Springs.
-And what do you guys --
what does this group of women
that everyone knows so well --
what do you do
on a birthday weekend?
-We pick a theme.
-Uh-huh.
-I mean, again, you would think
that that would mean
like greasers or something.
[ Light laughter ]
No, for mine,
I really wanted to wear muumuus
the whole time.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
And -- And I bought everybody
vintage bathing caps.
[ Laughter ]
And then...
And we were in a phase
where we were really enjoying
bitching about things.
-Okay.
-And so Spivey named it
the "Muumuu Nitpick."
[ Laughter ]
And then, we just, like,
floated around in a pool
and complained about stuff
you can't say a lot.
Like the parts you didn't like
in "Hamilton" --
like, stuff like that.
[ Laughter ]
-Right.
-You know --
like, things you can't say in
front of a lot of other people.
-Yeah, of course, right.
-So we just --
-No, it's very --
you want to be, like,
safely in the center of a pool.
-You just want to --
I mean you want to let it fly,
you know?
-Yeah.
-With some of the things
that aren't so fashionable
to say.
-And this is a photo
of some of you guys hanging out.
-Yeah, that's
a good time picture.
-That's a good time.
[ Laughter ]
-That's my favorite picture
of all time, actually,
because that's a bunch of idiots
who just had rosé at lunch
is what that is.
[ Laughter ]
-This is a cake
that was made for you.
-Oh, yeah, okay,
so, let me explain.
-Okay, yeah, yeah. Here.
-Let me explain. Let me explain.
Reveal. We got to --
I'm sorry -- I didn't mean to --
-No, no, please, please.
-I didn't mean to -- to harsh
your -- your reveal.
[ Light laughter ]
So, for our cakes, what we do,
which makes us laugh is,
we celebrate a character
that maybe wasn't as beloved.
-Sure.
-Because you know,
as people on the show,
your favorite moments
are either funny things that
happened in the writer's room...
-Yes.
-...or in rehearsal.
They're generally not the things
that everybody else enjoys.
-Right.
-So I -- I had
this character Deandra Wells,
who was moderately popular.
For -- For Dratch's birthday,
we did Abe Scheinwald.
-Yep.
-The accountant --
I mean the --
-Yep, double D's, double D's.
-Movie producer --
double D's, double D's.
-Yep.
-And we featured a cake
with flowers and a lot
of $20 and $50 dollar bills
coming out of it.
[ Light laughter ]
You can look at the --
look at the recognition
for Abe Scheinwald.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It was extraordinary.
You can Google it, so...
-You can Google it.
It's worth a Google.
-It's worth a real
satisfying Google.
-Yeah.
-And yours truly wrote it.
-And don't worry
you're gonna, like,
lose hours and hours watching
them -- there's only like two.
[ Laughter ]
-No, this was true
also of my sketch.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Deandra Wells,
who was a real -- a real [bleep]
Am I allowed to say that?
-Yeah, yeah.
-She --
She was a singer, very --
talked about love all the time,
but very abusive to her band.
So, hello, band.
Nice to see you guys.
[ Laughter ]
So we -- she --
she had -- she --
We had one with Conan O'Brien,
where she was real abusive
to him
while he was
coming out of rehab.
He was her son.
And it was set --
And for some reason, it was her
"Live in Santa Barbara" concert.
And for some reason,
when he finally explodes at her,
she turns to everybody --
the character -- and says,
"Not here,
not in Santa Barbara!"
as though it mattered.
Santa Barbara had nothing
to do with it.
-Right.
-So on my cake,
they did a giant blowup
of Deandra Wells.
And she did have icing
that said,
"Not here,
not in Santa Barbara!"
and with exploding candles,
so...
[ Cheers and Applause ]
-But now, this is --
-So much detail.
Again, I would say...
-But not in --
-...I would say Google it.
I'm sure
it's not on the Internet,
'cause NBC doesn't want to pay
for the music rights.
-Yes.
-So...
An, once again,
band, can I get a, "What what?"
-I was -- this was
very familiar to me,
because when I started
on the show...
-Yes.
-...in your office...
-...you had a giant oil painting
of Deandra.
-Yeah, it was huge.
It's absolutely huge.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, I'm not kidding.
I think it's 4 by 11 feet.
It's massive.
Because it was a sketch that
we took to dress and was cut.
It was --
It was cut because it bombed.
-Yeah.
-Pretty badly.
It was a -- It was a short --
a play --
- Yeah.
-A one-act play.
-And was it one of those
sketches
where you --
very early on, you knew,
"Oh, this is bombing, and we're
not gonna get it back?"
-No, it was a --
it was a Christmas special.
And we got real lost
in the details.
Paula and I wrote it together.
-Yeah.
-And we got real excited
about this giant self-portrait,
for example,
that she would have in her home.
She had -- It was a Christmas --
like a Christmas
variety special.
And she had -- And Val Kilmer
was playing Kris Kristofferson.
[ Laughter ]
And we had individual
jewel cases of CD covers
all over her Christmas --
We really -- We really
brought it in on the details.
But we forgot to write comedy...
-Right.
-...is the problem.
[ Laughter ]
And so, it was a play
about a woman
who had a Christmas special
that was bad.
I mean, I remember...
-Yeah.
-...it was, literally,
Big Bird came --
and it was --
and -- and small children.
It wasn't funny.
-And --
-But, anyway, so...
[ Laughter ]
...this portrait -- the --
Joe DeTullio...
-Yeah.
-...said to me, "Hey,
we got this giant portrait.
You want it in your office?"
Of course I said yes.
Because my office was...
-Yeah.
-...you know, about --
I don't know -- 10 square feet.
And so it took up
a lot of real estate.
-It took up all the space.
-It took up a lot
of real estate.
And then, when I left the show,
I guess it hung around
the writers' room for a while?
-It was there a long time.
[ Laughter ]
-It was --
It was my way of saying,
"I'm still here, friends."
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
The eyes followed you
when you walk across the room.
-Yeah, ex--
[ Laughter ]
So I ran into Andrew Steele --
I don't know --
a few years later.
It's like I can see
that portrait every day.
You might -- You might think
about getting that at home.
And weirdly,
I don't have any pictures
from "Saturday Night Live"
in my house.
But, strangely,
my husband really wanted this.
And so it hangs in my front hall
to this day.
And it's fantastic,
'cause there are people
who come into my home
who think
we had this commissioned.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
-Yeah.
'Cause it's not
a famous character.
-No.
-So they walk in,
and they're like,
"What -- So, did Charlie --
Was it your 40th or...?"
You know, they think --
You know,
it's like a Mar-a-Lago painting.
-It is.
-You know?
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's full Mar-a-Lago.
-Yeah.
I've got some Mar-a-Lago vibes.
-This is a nice --
this is a true story, though,
because you do have more
in common with Deandra
than you're letting on.
You actually do have a Christmas
album coming out this year...
-I do.
-...you yourself.
-Yes, "Sugar and Booze,"
October 25th.
[ Laughter ]
-That's very exciting.
-It's -- Well, it's --
it's better --
it's the best part
of the holidays, obviously.
-Yeah, "Sugar and Booze."
-Yeah, it's --
it's deeply religious...
[ Laughter ]
...and celebrates
the spirit of the holidays.
I look forward
to being back here.
Maybe I'll get to --
get to pitch it very overtly.
-Oh, wow, we would love
to have you come back...
-Yeah, I'm inviting myself
right now.
-...and sing a track
off "Sugar and Booze."
-I don't mean to put you on
the spot, but, yeah, why not?
-No, not on the spot at all.
You'll be on the spot --
center stage!
-Boom!
-Thanks for being here.
-Thank you for having me.
-It's always so great
to see you.
Everybody, that's Ana Gasteyer.
-Yay!